welcome to this video blitz video I had
some technical issue here so I'm bit
late lost a couple of seconds and when a
scotch game all right um yeah
recommended this line in my video series
the e4 e5 repertoire for blanket down I
constantly get some requests to continue
that series and I will certainly do this
will be completed but at the moment it's
it's difficult to to find the time so
many different chess related projects
that um that serious is somewhat um yeah
somewhat delayed their queen g4 this is
the most aggressive continuation I'm in
fact like and even continue 90 f six and
sacrifice some upon but I must admit I
forgot forgot how this line is exactly
played with Knight f6 so I went for this
simple continuation with Queen f 66
which also should be okay for black so
not as some forceful as an IDF 6 of
course but still um it shouldn't be a
big issue so just not have six this
could I could also exchange first
some of this move might be 50 is
irritating but that should be the big
big issue ok so now now I can take I
mean I could take before that this is
now look some quite comfortable
intending to get the bishop and it's a
bit awkward for him how does he make
sure that they don't damage his pawn
structure yeah not at all it seems but
what about this isn't now I that some
some stuff hanging right I can take here
I'm dumb okay if I take on d 2 is some
good f 7 m ok so let's let's capture
cell phone just here yeah I hope my
evaluation was correct that with the
booth them the better structure enter
the bishops I'm better
yeah I'd like to to stay on this this
diagonal v6b 61 but then I cannot really
manage I think I need to go back here
yeah the issue of course is some my king
position let's maybe a rookie one leaf I
have something like that but I've got
down haruka fade okay wait what do you
play on Luke evade so I'm now Bishop 286
since so good push up a six getting into
him into a pin yeah but suddenly I'm
okay for black his God Bishop e2 them
maybe it's better to go here still he
doesn't have fun great move with the
night yeah this one but I didn't think
it it was so dangerous I just thought it
would be offside on a five so not show
that this is a correct correct
evaluation I but this is this is so
weird move now the night doesn't have if
that doesn't have a retreat square so
really restraint okay so i can play
before of course but this is really
weakening
okay so let's try to get something going
in this way yeah you find but if I was
just the typical Sulu active move it's
not really doing much question as some
may be this if I've just g5 ideas
weakened himself here it is guys just
playing the aggressive moves that first
them come to its mind this is often
actually not a bad strategy okay not
lettin let's strategy as a head to too
big a word but it often works out fine
as so active moves are very often the
better moves in comparison to UM tour to
passive plane and yeah he's got some
pressure on d5
yeah don't have don't have a good move
quite sick actually okay cam some
somewhere I must have gone wrong yeah
okay this is not exactly a continuation
that worries black I just get e5 but I
spoil the big advantage before that's
the main problem now why damn at least I
shouldn't lose it has chances to try to
win of course with the upon go on some
hard to lose really he just put his King
in a very very bad spot on age three to
play Bishop f-22 g3 so this is I'm
threatening made gap now I'm winning at
least the position is winning now I can
promote
I'm very slow haha yeah the first game
of a session sometimes don't have I
don't have the speed it's a not not too
difficult to do to do yeah he guy was
coming from a really good position to to
a probably lost position I mean this is
just a very clear advantage for black he
misplaced the night on 85 and it's just
it's got weaknesses but the way I played
was um I was allowing him some activity
which is what which was really
unnecessary here can can play in
numerous things an easy way for example
is just Bishop f 6 35 with a pretty big
advantage or rugby aid I just need to
play something some something else then
then what I did I mean this this gives
white activity activity
rook air-five is still good and this now
is getting tricky at the computer
actually gives d4 with the big advantage
for black I didn't I thought about this
move briefly but I thought okay c6
hanging not still maybe it's good and
this now is so probably I'm probably
draw White has no your chance to make
any progress in five this weekend
black's pieces are fine yeah and then he
m just displayed this this already is
certainly quite good for black and here
it looks like em black is winning
already yeah thanks for watching